je pense que la question ce n'est pas
tellement de favoriser la cesse et que
deux ans on le vit les possibilités de
l'inceste
c'est de former une société dans
laquelle la sieste ne se présente plus
nissan automatique comme les
compatibilités
mais elle est une société alors c'est
une société qui n'a pas dray est
impensable une société à structure et
non des moindres des emplois en
connaissance de cause il ya trente ans
que j'étudie les structures de sociétés
animales je ne connais pas une seule
société animale qu'il soit structuré
vous voulez le faire avec l'homme êtes
vous sûr de ne pas aller contre la
nature dans une paroisse je suis sûr que
vous allez contre le siège de la société
ne sera pas fiable mais biologiquement
ne l'est pas plus modestes bon état mais
c'est déjà un gars nadine la famille et
gallas est la promiscuité ces maisons
dans lequel onze ans me semble
vous avez couché avec votre mère pour
dire que c'est la promiscuité c'est la
famille sculpté parce que j'aime la
chanson à la paix qu'il ya des gens qui
vivent dans une chambre
wimille il s'agit est effectué pour
tenir à leur mère pendant les faits
pendant alors mais rarement ceci je
connais la vallée parmi ceux ci au
modèle monsieur à sony de manacor tennis
twain a connu une issue mais dany son
taux mais le ballon dans les bras de
l'autre la maladie je sentais que ça
allait arriver
je crois que j'ai dit c'est que la
réforme de la société au point de
familière vous ne pourrez amener une
situation différente à nourrir le paddy
s'inclinant jeudi à légitimer et fut
intégré on relevait l'acidité soin de ta
bouche soit grèce est c'est à dire une
société différente
vous allez enlever j'aimerais chose à
est fondamental aux nappes une dignité
c'est le représentant de la chute
verticale ou le caillou qui tombe à
l'animalité
mais si c'est ce que vous voulez surtout
si nos ancêtres avaient marché dans le
sens animal nous ne serions pas là ce
soir
quirion pas la chance mais le problème
c'est que tout le monde et vous direz
c'est vrai que qu'il est très rare que
l'inceste se produisent dans la réalité
mais tout le monde en rêve de tout le
monde la danse on attendait une
affirmation tout gratuit c'est une impro
démissionner c'est une compo le raconter
ça s'appuie pas sur des faits n'ont pu
le vérifier a6 a6a s'appuie sur des
faits précis sur les mois c'est pas
scientifique
non mais vous aurez posé pas trop gras
c'est parce que je crois j'ai reçu
beaucoup de lettres lorsque j'ai dit que
nous avions fait une émission sur fox
j'ai reçu des lettres même d'un médecin
un médecin qui nous a dit j'espère que
vous allez dégonfler cette baudruche est
abominable torrent de boue et de l'avs
que freud a déversé sur l'occident donc
je pense qu'il ya encore en france les
gens et d'autant que son auteur qui
n'est pas encore tellement lui des gens
qui considèrent que free ne fait que
transformer tous nos gestes en geste
érotique c'est on ne peut plus fumer une
cigarette sans penser que c'est un geste
erratique donc des gens que ça j'aime
mon fils un enfant en danger
le professeur grassi encore des gens qui
pensent que l'algérie devrait être
française ait encore des gens qui
pensent que je veux dire y ait des
réactionnaires partout je vais dire mais
je n'ai pas été aussi jolie il faudrait
créer une nouvelle structure dans
laquelle l'inceste ne soit ni le tabou
n'existe pas et ni la possibilité
insiste mais c'est aussi oui parce que
le clapet de l'unss et streller
tentation de lens est 6e rang le peuple
de la famille mais quel est leur âge
elle qu'elle avait peur ici c'est que
différentes visions du monde voilà tous
les regards noirs n'avaient l'origine et
personne en parle c'est que la mer
c'était l'instrument nourricier alors
elle était tabou automatique mois on
n'allait pas détruire son instrument
nourrissions combat également un
problème dans deux gamines il est vrai
que par exemple dans certaines ce
problème résolu par la pilule oui
actuellement il commence à être résolus
comme étant il est vrai que par exemple
il ya quand même des modèles de parmi
les tribus polynésienne entend parler
tout à l'heure ou à l'intérieur d'un
clan structure est rituellement la mer
se chargent de l'initiation sexuelle de
l'enfant après quoi comme dans
d'ailleurs dans votre film
il ya évidemment il ya une période une
période intermédiaire de 15 jours où
l'enfant a le droit mais alors tout à
fait symboliquement de traiter mal sa
mère de l'humilier mais tout à fait
symboliquement après quoi il a le droit
de continuer de poursuivre ces
initiations avec n'importe quelle femme
de la tribu et à condition de ne pas de
ne pas franchir l'enceinte de la tribu
et du clan sinon il est exclu de
l'intériorité une vie tombe sur ce
bateau il ya neuf ans tout le monde le
sait oui je voudrais parler enfin oui
brière est remonté jusque jusque-là
horde sauvage enfin plus que le
professeur grasset dit que freud enfin
il fait peu de cas de fraude
à savoir que l'on exact où commence par
le meurtre du père où les fils oui
maintenant des [ __ ] la possession des
familles mentions dans le détail de tout
l'explication freudien parce qu'on va
pas le faire en 10 minutes mais je
voudrais demander c'est vrai que le
processeur grâce et nous précise ce
poids très important puisque je crois au
fond cette maj estime qu'il a eu un
certain courage aujourd'hui quelques
anciens potes courage campaign
on exprime ce que l'on sent non mais
vous estimez que vous dites dans
livre qu'à votre avis on n'a rien fait
sérieux sur l'inconscient et qu'il
faudrait commencer à prendre ça au
sérieux commencé à l'étudier
voici ce que j'aurai moi je veux dire
qu'il n'ya pas eu une biologie il n'y a
pas une expérimentation de l'inconscient
nous avons des interrogations de malades
des études mais rien ne nous prouve que
ces études ne pourrait pas être faite de
la conduite de la différemment avec un
thème tout autre j'ai pris un exemple
j'ai pris prenons le cas des enfants
on nous dit les enfants une sexualité là
il faudrait s'entendre
elle ne fait que très particulière et de
sexualité entre 10 et 11 en août et un
enfant normal n'est pas intéressant ne
faut en fait je disais ceci je me disais
que dans le l'étude de l'inconscient
n'est ce pas justement c'est ce qui me
chiffonne cette étude d'inconscient n'a
pas été poussé
si vous voulez d'une manière
scientifique biologie elle est
l'expression de de vue théorie et nous
pourrions complètement changé cela dit
l'elysée et de la mort lui dit pas non
monsieur russell la scientifique
gilad beaucoup dans l'exemple enfin la
vie vous donner un exemple immédiat
pourquoi l'inceste et il réprime et
c'est parce que vous allez avoir une
génie d une descendance effroyable pour
béziers le contraire sur les animaux je
pense à l'immense on servira ligne mais
ça aurait coûté
contrat ou si vous avez salon si vous
avez des guérites harry l'actuel c'est
différent sa famille c'est pour paul
intense met la culture
mais ce n'est pas une question
biologiste quand on fait des enfants
très beau mais ça dépend des cas ce que
vient de débuter voyons c'est qu'on en
train de donner des exemples dans le
mariage marié pas là on se maniant tu le
mets c'est pour ça qu'il faudrait
généricables exemple est ingénieur et
4000 ans et n'ont pas duré quatre mille
ans
il y avait des esclaves qui a porté les
enfants normaux
parce qu'ils étaient exogamie mai mais
historiquement historiquement ce n'est
pas parce que vous dites moi ce que
l'historiquement le tabou de l'inceste
est antérieure à la constatation où
l'abbé vous avec l histoire il faut même
sort dans quoi allez vous référant aux
médecines tlm et si ya pas de médecine
de sa lame et le fina décousu m
les ondes et les tribunes mariages
consanguins
après le tabou mais les mariages
que vous le vouliez ou non en génétique
sont des catastrophes
je peux vous en venir les eaux amer et
de sens est interrompue
la seconde n'a rien à faire la clé une
vision du monde qui était cohérente qui
est un monument qui durera pendant
longtemps comme mars d'ailleurs ce sont
des visions du monde sur quels lots
niane rendement les clients délecter du
poids du de la biologie ou de la science
parce que la ccit de margaux en forme et
si c'est conforme phénomène mais cet
honneur en soirée la direction de
l'humanité qui est beau mon sens c'est
une vue purement théorique
ça n'a aucun fondement mais même pas de
fondement fils y fait même pas de
fondement philosophique à écouter je
crois que là j'ai voulu faire cette
parenthèse sur le freudisme puisque nous
reparlerons treuil de la semaine
prochaine et qu'il était intéressant que
professeur grasset nous dise quand tombe
bien le gisti contre est ce que j'aurai
nul mais se reparler du un peu de
l'inconscient
nous n'avons pas parlé de la crise
attitude le premier en pensez vous
puissent étudier l'inconscient des gens
qui ont essayé tout de même prenons un
exemple jamais pour le jeune manon et
santé non je n'ai pas scientifique dans
votre vie vous donner l'exemple d'un de
vos propres rêves qu'est ce que nous
allons faire du ski sincèrement serait
vous le donnez pas ce que vous pensez
qu'il a une certaine signification c'est
l'amour pour moi c'est joli j'avais peur
mais oui mais vous ne pensez pas que
freud a quand même étudié les rêves et a
donné quelques indications quelques
indications sur la manière de
l'interpréter de comprendre les rêves
oui sans doute mais bon qu'est ce qui
vous justifie lorsque vous dites que ce
rêve parle de la mort parlement puisque
c'est j'avais peur je ne pouvais pas
voir
je n'ai pas dit dans mon lit je ne
pouvais pas voir un squelette il me
faisait une peur intense jeu le fallait
peur de la mort voilà ce que j'avais
comme moi je crois de presse à gaza que
votre refus de freud mériterait
psychanalytique la merveille des
résultats magnifiques
je sais combien de cas ni écoutés voit
ce que vous trouverez le résultat de
cette psychanalyste dans un livre de j
d'andré gide roi qu'il a donnée je
voudrais 2ème des régions grâce à se
demander c'est lui aussi l'a rencontré
dieu en france or je crois je crois
l'avoir en compte dans la même église n
ont pas dans une église je les trouvais
peut-être au sommet de la science et sap
je ne pense pas que nous rencontrions au
même point écoutez je reviens à ce
problème du tabou abordé est dépassé par
louis mas que j'aurais demandé je crois
certains d'entre vous est peut-être un
monsieur au plateau cécile un sentiment
que aujourd'hui on peut dépasser
je crois que nous avons fait une petite
déviation subtile fallait encourager ou
décourager la scène je crois que c'est
pas du tout de problème que pose nue mal
problème est que il montre avec
franchise un problème débarrasser de
tout ce qu'il a à 2 me de magie de
sacrées de religieux est ce que vous
pensez qu'aujourd'hui parce que frein
lui était encore dans le magique il
était encore dans le sacré des temps
comme la société puritaine de la fin du
19e siècle à vienne et peut-être que son
oeuvre un certain décalage par rapport à
ces jeunes générations et ce que je
pense c'est que louis dumas l'a fait
quand même un film qui est je sais pas
l'air du temps d'aujourd'hui c'est à
dire de ces 1971 100 films bien qui se
passe en 56 mais enfin je veux dire
qu'on n'aurait pas fait ce film en 56
s'impose 4 54 est ce que vous pensez que
chez les jeunes clients vous pouvez
avoir
il ya cette libération cette capacité de
transformer par le rire et d'humour des
problèmes graves qui autrefois a créé
des névroses il ya quand même des
problèmes graves qui doivent rester
crash
je ne parle pas seulement des questions
section et dans d'autres domaines pense
pas qu'on puisse tous tourné à la
rigolade c'est impossible
pourquoi pas qu'est-ce que alors
entendons-nous sur la question
d'harmonie est-ce que la rigolade ça
veut dire que peu importe
jeanne alençon ce que nous pensons ce
que je crois nous sommes entrés dans un
ce qui me fera beaucoup dans la nouvelle
génération et moi je me trouve vraiment
comme leurs grands frères avec une joie
immense
c'est qu'ils ont décidé de tout
dédramatiser y compris la politique par
exemple
non ainsi les meilleurs d'entre eux si
le meilleur ah oui non pas nombreux
absolument et que si vous voulez il y a
par exemple ce qui était tout de même la
chose qui nous reste de mai 68 c'est que
c'était une grande fête et nous n'en
parlerons dans quinze jours d'un livre
de 2,2 des hippies de rubine do it kiki
dont les deux paires leçon groucho marx
ah ben voilà groucho marx et karl marx
alors évidemment là je crois qu'on a des
dates dédramatiser la politique dans ce
pays non mais ce que je veux dire c'est
que finalement
si vous les donne dans la civilisation
occidentale il y à cette espèce de
lourdeur et ce sérieux cette façon de
toujours parler de tout avec une sorte
de gravité fondamentale qui est quelque
chose que je crois dans la nouvelle
génération
ils sont en train de secouer vraiment
très profondément et ça je trouve que
c'est bien
[Musique]